[Music]
welcome back to a very special episode
of careful boys where we are indeed very
careful boys super careful today we got
anthony lee pretty exciting hey whoa i
haven't sat in a seat in a long time
didn't your boy mike song come out with
the app it's pretty sick man my song
specifically like song what mike song
taking all the beats
making the big moves man i had a dream
about mike song one day never met him
was i closed on yeah all right nice he
was in the dream and i was like oh i
know anthony league and that was the
whole dream
what did he say after that was he like
embarrassed or was he like he just
looked at me like perplexed in my dream
he just was like
like i didn't exist him in your dream
how [ __ ] i'm gonna talk to him have
you ever had someone come up to you and
they they um they make sure that they
know that you're a tuber but they want
you to let somebody else know that they
say hi
can you play the scenario out okay
yeah so it's like it's like hey uh
hey uh yeah you're on jk right hey can
you tell joe what's up
[Laughter]
i can't say that that one's happened
yeah not about you but that happens
oh where's david or where is this person
how the [ __ ] do i [ __ ] know i'm just
here [ __ ] buying water and [ __ ] yeah
david's in torrance
[Laughter]
where else would he be jesus christ oh
so you saw my song of dreams
[Laughter]
the creative freedom that you could have
and that's what you chose yeah nikki did
tell me that she was playing poker last
night and she was like she's like
there's this guy who's jk fan and he
just kept on asking me what bart's
workout regimen was
like i [ __ ] know she's like i [ __ ]
know oh so annoying i'm so sorry nikki
that's [ __ ] good to work out right
now good question i'll show you guys the
texture i feel like that's a good
question though right what's your
workout regimen before we get to this
this stupid thing big macs
i do the kinjaz workout regimen that you
can get on the kenjus dojo
for your cardio that's why you got abs
right i do reps on a me sandwich
no this is awesome so you built the
[ __ ] app huh it's uh it's technically
not an app's online dance tutorial
platform we call it just dojo for
beginners okay finally teaching people
how to dance huh no dude about time
online give back to your community jesus
christ you [ __ ] um
i think you know the crazy thing is uh
when the studio or when the pandemic
happened and we had to close the studios
before we closed them down there was
this moment where we're like oh we
should take things online and a lot of
people were doing that right everybody
started jumping on like that like what
was taboo or what was like not cool
before in a purist artist form it's like
i'm not gonna take online dance classes
suddenly every [ __ ] person and their
mom was like throwing platforms isn't
that funny when they gotta survive they
finally throw away their pride
it's so true
it was like nah [ __ ] that man i'm
[ __ ] beer man i'm never gonna go
[ __ ] mainstream and [ __ ] they're like
i can't pay the bills i'm not working at
mcdonald's i'm gonna teach you how to
[ __ ] dance online this will never go
digital
i'll never go i need a [ __ ] personal
personal person man
people within the industry though are
usually the hardest on themselves like
when when you started telling me about
you guys were gonna take it online i
thought it was the sickest [ __ ] ever but
then when you're telling me how like um
oh i don't know or whatever and i'm like
i don't get it i just feel like i think
artists are the hardest on themselves
and they feel like they're gonna i don't
know sell it out or do whatever but you
never know who they're selling out to or
who their own personal enemy is for me i
just from the outside i'm just like oh
it makes perfect sense they're [ __ ]
expanding they're crushing it yeah yeah
well you don't understand you're not a
real artist but dancer the dancer that's
true
from dancer to dancer i was
i was kind of embarrassed that you sold
out like that bro
because i never saw my art you know what
i mean like
we sold out super hard because uh we're
not even doing the advanced stuff there
it's all just beginner stuff so oh my
god bro super hard sell out so it's just
this left side and that's it
because he has the inside of his right
arm
doesn't even connect it just stops here
really where the inspiration really
comes from though is like when we
actually before the pendant when we had
the dojo right um after abdc is when we
crowdfunded on indiegogo and we were
able to get a bunch like over a hundred
thousand dollars to open up the kinder
dojo in monterey park
that's more money than we got for
beating you
[Laughter]
someone give ryan a microphone [ __ ]
drop it from the [ __ ] top of the
ceiling
i try to point that out you guys did
better in the long run look at that [ __ ]
up that's true this guy dude is a gemini
though cause you you like stop there
i've never met anyone who chills more
than you it's
out of all of us ryan's the biggest
[ __ ] winner
yeah the biggest killer and ryan's just
chill like we're all talking about
exciting stuff and ryan's like so what
are you guys up to and he's like he's
and he'll just suddenly sit there and
he's like all right i bought some
he throws it away like a duck happens
when you're worth 19 million dollars
that's the attitude you live he's got
energy dude
retirement
he's hired no but that's great dude
that's great dude ryan sitting here he's
like i heard some people pay rent huh
how does that work
directly you pay at the beginning or the
end of the month you give them a check
did they take
that it's clearly more lucrative to get
second do a gofundme and then you end up
with more profit
that's [ __ ] me with more work
that was 100k and go go fund me uh it
was the indiegogo campaign yeah dude
so we open the studio we're on our high
horse totally like like the highest
we've ever been this is 2015 or whatever
right and then i remember all of us were
like all right let's we're gonna [ __ ]
teach our community so we started
booking out all the classes all the
kinders are teaching this advanced [ __ ]
and i remember a handful of us maybe
we're getting like full classes but for
the most part the amount of people one
who will uh want to dance like hip-hop
is already kind of like a small bubble
and then number two like learn it from
asian people like especially back then
dude and then like level three it's like
kind of more like iso stuff so it's like
really really advanced too like who's
even good enough to even be at that
level to learn something so we would
always get like these we'd always get
like these uh you know these tall lanky
asian kids like myself that were like
head to toe and kendra's gear they're
super fans and they'd be like oh my god
it's my first class
oh wow [ __ ]
this is really hard and they're like
discouraged because it's too hard yeah
but they would have a good time but at
the same time like consciously as a
teacher you know of a small studio too
so it's not like thousands of people in
class you're just kind of like [ __ ] this
is a really hard routine i i'm just
gonna have fun with it you know what i
mean and it would work but then we would
find out that
the beginner's classes when it really
wasn't even about the choreography combo
or who the teacher was
suddenly everyone was signing up for
those classes and they would build their
community within themselves and they
they would practice in the parking lot
they created their own facebook group a
lot of passion yeah because and they
would just meet new people along this
kind of beginner's journey that had way
less pressure to like you know there's
also a little bit of that toxic culture
in like dance classes too where it's
like everyone's trying to be seen
everyone wants to be acknowledged you
like kill it
yeah and then like get competitive like
in your class dude
like the most swaggiest 3 000 balenciaga
outfit just to make sure that like when
the camera's on you're like freestyling
after the routine hopefully you get
booked for some like nonchalant concept
afterwards but
that makes me want to wear a beret and a
[ __ ]
glasses and go you what is your name i'm
gonna make you famous
star you see right in dude you would fit
right here ryan knows what i'm talking
about
he's going to be standing there with a
clipboard what is your name oh my god
those moves that's important that's part
of the economy now like it just happened
to become that way it's so weird it's
it's just how it is right it's the
culture but but now when we started
seeing the beginner classes again
without even knowing who the teacher was
everyone would just sign up because they
knew they were gonna have a good time i
was like why are we trying so hard you
know what i mean to like do such an
advanced and complicated thing that's
difficult for us as creators always
trying to outdo our last routine as well
when there's so many more people that
find joy in just connecting
not necessarily becoming the best in the
world i think i think it's harder it's
harder to teach beginners classes too
because they sell stupid
because
because they're such a balenciaga
what's that is
peter pan's shadow dude one hat away
from a zorro costume [ __ ] peter pan
shadows dude so so it's hard to i think
it's harder because because this is a
funny thing about it it's like you have
to be a super good dancer already and
then you have to go back to your first
frame of mind on what made you fall in
love with it way back in the beginning
so you kind of have to gloss over all
the things that you're doing now and
it's like how do i connect with this
person so that i don't make it
intimidating you know it's like super
difficult to do that not every teacher
even can do that at all online so you're
only doing it to a camera and never
actually interacting with the student
but just needing to feel what it must be
like right to be a beginner with what
you're doing so you're like it's like a
weird sense of empathy in like a
non-physical environment yeah it's kind
of like isolated a little bit yeah but i
mean it's the future you know what i
mean it's like it would be it would be
foolish to just be like nah like
old school everybody come to the studio
if you want to train you know in these
two hours today's video is brought to
you by masterworks masterworks allows
anyone to become a shareholder in
legendary artworks from the likes of
picasso banksy and basquiat to name just
a few whereas in the past you needed
millions for that level of art now
anyone can invest with masterworks
here's some reasons why masterworks is
worth the investment contemporary art
prices outpaced the s p 500 total return
from 1995 all the way to 2020 by 106
percent
contemporary art has a price
appreciation of 23 on average when
inflation is above 3
and that's happening right now
contemporary art prices have appreciated
14
annually on average from 1995 to 2020.
unlike some assets that can be printed
out out of thin air
there's only a very limited supply of
this asset such as this painting we have
over there made by bart
the unfinished sun it's a thousand
ethereums
it's one of a kind
and as time progresses the supply will
only continue to become more scarce
making it more sought after diversify
your portfolio with an asset that
actually performs better when inflation
is high and our listeners get to skip
the wait list just go to masterworks dot
art slash record see important
disclosures and regulations at
masterworks dot io slash cd that's
masterworks dot art slash record yeah
which we still do that we still do all
of it at our advanced workshops like
that but to like really still be able to
reach people i mean some of our biggest
fans are like india the philippines
brazil you know what i mean all these
places that can't come to la and train
i've always wanted to learn something
and wanting to learn something from us
because they saw us on nbc or whatever
it's not like
i want to learn how to do the sense and
do the hardest combo ever
it's like i just i kind of want to just
learn some of the moves and like
understand what that's like you know so
so hopefully this is just like a
a step towards being able to reach all
those people and and also for us dude as
a business that you know having to close
the studios
that [ __ ] was tough you know it feels
kind of like a failure in a sense even
though it's like it is it really is it
totally is a failure yeah our good
friends are like it's not really your
fault our bad friends are like it's a
failure uh it's totally your fault says
bart quan or hurt quan over here but to
be able to like try again and to find
out i don't see mcdonald's closing
[Laughter]
franchises
multi-billion dollar corporation always
see trillion dollars dairy queens and
[ __ ] do you know what you do see yeah
soup plantation you see old pizza hut
buildings and they're not pizza building
i know yeah
but they're a pizza hut buildings yeah
right they're really good they're pizza
hut drills don't miss
or or wind chills because you know they
got the [ __ ] smooth triangles
remember circuit city oh circuit city
where they had the [ __ ] circuit in
the middle of the [ __ ] thing
that's in the clouds
i didn't know that you needed a whole
store for that many wires
and i didn't know why my dad kept
getting more
but we had boxes full of wires in his
closet and i guess it gave him joy
i also don't know how sears is still
liquidating and still closing i don't
get that either just a real estate
company now they just have [ __ ] tons of
real estate that's like their whole
business i feel like sears has been like
closing down for like 15 years it's a
great way to get people in the store
that's true i've seen them running one
montabella has been closing for 10 years
right yeah i've been to series a bunch
of times and every time i'm there an
employee commits suicide
the lights are always like the
fluorescent lights are always like
really dingy and dark so dark jesus
flickering yeah it's bad in there
i think i think you were right at the
cusp of understanding your market and
then the pandemic came because i think
this is your true demographic all right
there's asian girls
all over the world that want to be
defiant and say no i'm not going to be a
[ __ ] doctor mom no pharmacist here
you know i'm going to be a dancer and
[ __ ]
but because they're very goal-oriented
and they want structure and class and
they want to get grades and [ __ ]
a dance school is the perfect place
where you can look like a rebel but
still be scholastic you know what i mean
scholastic rebels that's not the type of
rebel but still be scholastic yeah
that's gonna be great and [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] diplomacy you guys are talking
about it i'm gonna hire joe to be the
guy who gives out grades
because you shouldn't okay this is what
you should do okay you got your after
school program right with the defiant
asian girls that are just like nah [ __ ]
that would be kpop you know and then you
got like
you got the morning and afternoon
classes for the chinese grandmas
so
the stretchers all generations of asian
women
and there's a huge market for that
huge my free advice is giving you right
now
yeah yeah
this is christ i'm a genius marketer and
i don't know why you don't take this
stuff no i'm taking it all right dude
look like a rebel but still be a
scholastic yeah that's pretty funny i
like that he's like what the [ __ ] is
going on out here he's like this is
where the asian grandmas are supposed to
be yeah
we talked about this this is where they
learn their self-defense
you know what's cool though that i like
is that there's not a lot of dancers in
the industry that kind of grew to the
level that they did
where they're still teaching basics like
they're most of those dancers are only
teaching advanced or master so it's dope
at doing that i don't know if you guys
ever seen this footage of with twins
teaching in class
whether it's like it's like a room of
200 kids trying to take la twins class
and of course you're so [ __ ] famous
that everyone's gonna want to take it
out but no one can do one thing that's
like mike tyson this room with 200
people are just doing random [ __ ] is is
that kind of the standard in like the
dance industry where like most people
i think you just get to a level as a
teacher you want to teach what you think
is dope or beneficial so like you know
what's rewarding to yourself yeah you
know what but also nothing you can't
help that a bunch of random fans are
going to take your class either you know
oh yeah but mike imagine mike tyson
is like teaching a master class
you guys are teaching a master class but
for the beginner class hey put your
hands up trying to survive for 30
seconds what
try to survive
so like just walk up to the guy just
knock his [ __ ] ass out like he's
[ __ ] hard
get him on your website i would take a
class
100
computer class with a guy i don't care
what it is
a computer class yeah it could be cl he
could be doing clay pots and [ __ ] i
think mike tyson should teach a master
class on pigeon training
yeah he's like really into that
is he really yeah yeah dude [ __ ] room
in las vegas
his wife didn't mike
didn't mike tyson's like ex-girlfriend
or wife or something like edith pigeon
was dude i don't know it sounds it
sounds real
it sounds like something
i think the pigeon was named robin kids
maybe i'm tripping that's a that's a
funny thing to trip on but i made that
up
his wife ate his [ __ ] guy
has he talked about it a bunch on his
podcast and stuff i feel like he got
like really upset and like did he did he
ever beat his wife like he kind of has a
documentary about like him
sending pigeons out i feel like his wife
cooked his pigeon when she was pissed at
him or some [ __ ] so he like beat her
i can hear him getting stoned on his
podcast and he's like man these pensions
they really understand you
honestly if you type that into google
right now i bet you could find that i
bet you find that exact clip there's
like two my tysons though there's one
that like i'll [ __ ] kill the world
and then there's the new like guru um
it's the weed sensitive guy that's the
weirdest
do you see the video where he was at
like a comedy show or something like
that a guy pulled out a gun yeah and
then there was like a big scuffle and
afterwards mike tyson like sees him
gives him a hug and they hug it out he
defused it pretty well was someone
trying to shoot mike tyson i guess two
other guys were fighting one guy pulled
the gun out and then mike tyson was like
hey man like what's up and he gave him a
hug and i think it was all good what's
mike tyson he just went up to a [ __ ]
dude it's crazy he was sitting there
watching it at sunset there's like a
comedy show and this dude came in and
wanted to meet mike and he started
telling mike yo like we should do a
fight so it'll help me like gain some
notoriety this random guy and then the
security dude was like trying to kick
him out and then the dude just pulled
out a gun and cocked it and then
everyone just kind of stopped [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] mad and then he goes he was
just like i'm just playing man it was
just a joke
and then everyone's just like yo dude
and then my april
yeah mike was like no just come here
just come here and then he just like
dabbed him and then dude put it away and
then and then as he walked out he was
like he went back to security guys i
could have blown your brains out in
front of everyone and then he just left
they let him leave no charges
[ __ ] real game oh i thought he was
holding the head of that guy
tyson too so so what's your what how do
people go uh take your take your class
with mike tyson in it yeah yeah um so uh
all they they do is uh if you check on
like instagram or all of our ads that
we've been posting like consistently for
like the last week um there's a link
and then it's it's built on this
platform called you screen which a lot
of different creators like put out types
of content like that so it's super easy
and [ __ ] you can go [ __ ] on your tv
tv or a tablet or phone or whatever the
[ __ ] um and it just has all the
tutorials right there they're all
beginners their skills and drills and
stuff it's [ __ ] 12.99 a month which
is
like less than a single class but you
know you have [ __ ] 30 videos there
already and we do four videos a month or
it's 120 bucks for the whole year so
it's like 10 months to see as a
someone who's maybe interested in
dancing
like we're
we just pretend i'm a master but we're
gonna pretend that i don't know nothing
and i'm like all right
oh dance i always wanted to dance and i
click oh okay i'm gonna buy
and then now what's the first thing i
see first thing you got to buy is a zoot
suit
cherry popping daddy i got the hat
already you know that's what i'm saying
turn on some zapping rods okay so what's
the first thing um is it like because
it's scary like it's like oh this is
just so perfect and professional why we
wanted to build the platform too uh
because it's all beginner stuff it's
super super easy for somebody who has
never danced before to go on because
most people are like like all that
dancing is really cool i want to do that
but you don't know how to go from like a
to z everybody's trying to jump to z you
know what i mean whereas like with these
classes when you jump in you're gonna
see [ __ ] b c d e f g style like
classes that are just depending on your
framework depending on your style
depending on your speed or your comfort
or maybe you already really are familiar
with the songs we're just using a lot
more like you know when we choreograph
advanced stuff sometimes you're always
trying to like find the most innovative
sounds
and then nobody knows what song is and
that's what makes it exciting whereas
over here we're going to do like all
your favorite songs top 40 [ __ ] so if
you already have a familiarity you're
like oh i already knows do a leap a song
then memorizing the steps to it is
actually going to be a lot easier for
you you know when the hook is going to
start or the verse or whatever you know
when she says this you know oh okay cool
and then as you sing it in your own head
that's what beginners do a lot they're
like kind of like mouthing or humming or
singing the song themselves they'll be
able to like associate that with really
basic steps um
is honey like the most iconic dance
movie
yes
nobody but seriously no no which one is
this ass ass ryan what's the most in
honey too i'm not going to ask ryan
you got served i think it depends on
what style if you want to go hip hop i
think maybe you guys serve the most
iconic because of what it was at that
time yeah it depends
that was our introduction in the rainbow
people say beach street some people say
isn't it technically black swan though
that's the most prestigious
save the last dance no
what about what's that one right it's
like i had the time of my life and the
guy picks her up swayze uh ghost
great [ __ ] dance that's the best
dance movie that's a great dance movie
dude should we all learn a routine and
then practice
it refer to all of us
we should take a class at the kinja
studios as the careful boys dude i think
i think if i take that class you're
gonna afterwards ask me to join the
kimchi's dude i'm actually gonna buy a
balenciaga outfit right now
we should go there dressed like dancers
and then we could try to show off
can you teach us a class
yes small short class yeah once you sign
up for 12.99 i'm going to i'm going to
you are a kenja are there are you don't
need to sign up anymore
are there different tiers or is it 12.99
for like everything it's 1.99 for
everything a month or 120 for the whole
year oh okay that's it oh nice cool
so we're just hoping a bunch of people
sign up and then forget that their
account's logged in
dude some dudes hourly rate for privates
is higher than that
what's the refund policy
can they sign up and i learned for a
week and they get their money back no
it's a rug pull
we just bounce
satisfaction guaranteed no hell no 2022
dude
[Music]
you